from the country well i'm joined now by
nadiri who's a member of afghanistan's
high council
for national reconciliation and is a
former senior advisor
to president ashraf ghani very good to
talk to you
um first of all can we we start with
this explosion
in kabul i don't know if you have any
more information about it it appears to
have
blown up in the green zone itself
therefore
an attack at the very heart of the
capital
yes a terrible news from kabul again
and it was a terrible attack and
shook many people inside the capital but
at the same time
you know that many people tonight in
kabul with other provinces
started reciting that allahu akbar
the god is greater as a support to the
afghan national army
this this incident has been
devastating but even though you
mentioned that
no one has claimed this attack but i
personally believe that i think many
people even
in afghanistan believe similar to what i
believe that taliban are
somehow responsible if it directly comes
from them or
indirectly because uh we need peace in
afghanistan at this time and the afghan
people
are have been raising their voice
clearly so far for a peaceful
afghanistan want to go through a peace
process
but since taliban has been very
aggressive towards
the peace process in afghanistan and
they have been attacking different
provinces
even the attack that doesn't come
directly from them the responsibility
must be attached to them because
they are bringing such a kind of uh
violation
of um the peace process as well as you
know
encouraging more violence than than
bringing an uh
peace meaning there is not that much uh
intention
of taliban um towards the peace process
even though
officially they keep saying that they
are you know um
they they they believe in the peace
process and they want to carry on with
it but we need
action well tell me more broadly about
your fears for
afghanistan with this renewed taliban
offensive and
in the context of the peace deal you
refer to
done with the united states with the
coalition partners which has
led to is leading to the complete
withdrawal of american and british and
other troops from afghanistan do you
think
that that policy led by president biden
is the correct one
well i'm keep saying and i repeat once
again the withdrawal
of international um army
or our partners from afghanistan after
20 years
is making sense but the way this
withdrawal has been taken place
it has been very irresponsible and
you see if it was not irresponsible
we wouldn't face such a kind of problem
after 20 years in afghanistan you know
after
uh after a win background was
um uh given to
uh the the
u.s army when they left bagram uh
the whole um panic started from there
and we went through
a district clubs one after another
and um the kind of evacuation
uh was irresponsible in many ways
that we are still suffering you see a
lot of you know even your in
your um screen right now showing
different
um afghans being displaced and
many provinces went through terrible
experiences
that they they brought up the not only
the trauma of
20 years ago what afghan people went
through during tariban's regime
but also even cruel scenes
let me just talk about one of the
incidents beside
what happened in kabul right now from
bal that one of the
afghan women was
killed because the way she was dressed
today and the way she came out of the
home without any man companion she was
actually
killed by um by taliban but of course
they denied
again let me clarify that any area that
is under the control of taliban and such
a kind of cruel action happens
it directly or indirectly it's attached
to the action of taliban because they
have been
uh emerging themselves
again into power through violence and
through
falls that actually you know um
giving so much encouragement to so many
criminal people
who directly or indirectly see
themselves as soldiers of taliban
and taliban must take responsibility to
these actions even if they have not
directly you know committed such a kind
of
atrocities plus you know that areas that
has been taken controlled by taliban
unfortunately in these areas
the circulation of information is is
cutting off
for different reasons because first of
all when we talk about freedom of media
or freedom of
speech you have to have security in
order to have security
i mean uh freedom of the speech but when
uh in the area under control of taliban
the
information or the circulation of
information is cutting off
it shows that everyone knows that
taliban doesn't commit themselves in
these values
and if they don't so the
journalists do not feel secure to
actually you know give information about
the realities that happens
what happens in those areas the taliban
are taking control
and tell me more about your fears in
particular
for women in afghanistan if there is a
full or even a
a partial taliban retake over
all those young girls young women who
are able at the moment
to access education will that
could that end and what about what about
your own safety would you fear for that
well uh to be frank with you
in the recent years and especially
within this one year and within these
months
the women's rights in afghanistan has
been severely
violated even our international partners
in afghanistan the way they were
listening to
women's voices they don't listen to the
same level that they were doing it
before
for instance within this course of one
year our international partners
who was a very strong advocate of
women's rights in afghanistan
they have been forget about taliban side
they have been trying to replace afghan
women by afghan men
and actually um somehow giving this kind
of authority to afghan men
to that they can protect women's rights
i mean
we have been fighting for 20 years
against this
you know um patriarchal society
while we are facing a very um
you know a a kind of group that has been
violating women's rights to the level
that the whole world knows about
it before facing them our voice has been
um badly affected inside the country
among those afghan men who has been our
colleagues so
some kind of indirect guarantee is
giving to men
inside afghanistan even during the peace
process
that they would feel superior to women
and somehow if they want they can
guarantee some rights for women
meaning that if you give so much
attention to men inside afghanistan
within the regime you are violating
directly women's rights and you're
undermining their
struggles their fights and the
leadership of women inside afghanistan
then what kind of rights you can get
guaranteed from
you know from international sorry from
from taliban side
let me um highlight this fact that
even if you read the um
you know the statement that was given by
uh eu and u.s
in the um past weeks
you just see women's rights as a
generalized notion
while you see in reality in the areas
that is taken by taliban
it's mainly the women who has been
affected badly
they cannot freely go outside their
house
they cannot really without the companion
of a man
cannot go and do their routine as they
were used to do it
and their dressing quotes again
scrutinized by
by taliban and if it's not appropriate
according them they can easily kill them
and they deny it the next day yeah well
i mean it is such a concerning and
worrying situation thank you so much
indeed for joining us on sky news
tonight to to tell us all about it thank
you very much
indeed